on et
allez on embarque maintenant cap sur le
grand bleu l'association plongeurs
chirac nous emmène à la découverte de
l'épave de la is yang qui veut dire
qu'il veut dire cochons sauvages c'est
une des plus belles de l'île informe
osant de 49 mètres posait bien droit à
54 mètres de fond au large des aigrettes
là ils s'y rendent c'est un bateau
formose ans qui a été coulé dans les
années 80 suite à un trafic
de la pêche illégale il me semble
il se situe sur 54 55 mètres sur un fond
sableux très poissonneux
colorer
les pavés très belle aussi c'est une
belle et paf que je connais depuis
longtemps depuis depuis 84 et
jeu j'affectionne particulièrement ceux
ci ce site là
pour ces raisons
l'eau est limpide c'est idéal puisque on
se met à l'eau et tout de suite 5 10 m
plus tard on voit déjà les pavots faut
de poser sur le fond on aperçoit déjà le
mât et on descend à la verticale c'est
assez rare mais ça arrive ça m'est
arrivé plusieurs fois essayé c'est
exceptionnel c'est de toute beauté
c'est le principe de dcp c'est à dire
qu'au début
l'epa avait coulé il ya un bateau au
fond et puis la faune et la flore
s'approprie s'était pas et c'est
colonisé tout doucement et là je pense
que c'est un maximum
moi aussi je fais un petit peu de photo
et mon plaisir c'est de de prendre ces
nuages de poissons jaune rouge très
colorés des poissons pierre des murènes
c'est ça pour moi
fun
vraiment la plongée
type
pour les plongeurs expérimentés
m
à
de ce canal